[Music]
on this Sunday night the military
mobilizes to Newfoundland the rush to
get troops on the ground we're also
reminded that Newfoundland is very much
an island and the race to dig out after
record-breaking snow no banks are so
high he can even get over the federal
plan to rewrite Canada's assisted dying
legislation plus the princes perspective
on his new common life in Canada what I
want to make clear is we're not walking
away
global national with Robin Gill good
evening and thank you for joining us
help is arriving in Newfoundland and
Labrador as the province digs out from
an historic snowfall Canadian forces
have mobilized to assist with the
recovery in areas that have been buried
in nearly a meter of snow but the
federal government is warning there will
be logistical problems times like this
of course we're also reminded that
Newfoundland is very much an island and
at times like this it makes it even more
challenging to make sure that we get the
resources in place that we need to get
there a state of emergency will remain
in effect until at least Monday in st.
John's and other hard-hit communities
but before Newfoundlanders have even had
the chance to finish clearing up this
pile of snow another storm is set to
move in Mike Armstrong has our top story
tonight walking down the middle of this
street glenda 9 is about a meter off the
ground it's a little tougher when he
steps off the road
denying left home Sunday to see his
granddaughter she was supposed to have a
party for her 6th birthday but like just
about everything else in Newfoundland
it's canceled despite the struggle to
get to the door it turned out not to be
working the only way to get his
granddaughter out come on I think is by
the window little Olivia's father Josh
denying tried to keep the door cleared
during the storm but lost the battle
between Friday morning and Friday night
I was out and cleared cleared a doorway
away four or five times before I gave up
at it because it was just too much it
was coming down too fast
this was not a normal storm it wasn't
just the amount of snow but how it was
blown about
but it left will take time to clean up
how much time is the question snow
removal crews are busy and exhausted but
until their work is done people are
stuck against each other now that ain't
going over anyway not open
an official state of emergency remains
in effect in Saint John's and several
other communities people are still
supposed to stay at home
however some restrictions have been
lifted pharmacies were allowed to open
so people can get medicine and gas
stations are now allowed to sell fuel as
long as it's for snow removal vehicles
snowblowers or generators about 3,000
homes are still without electricity
Newfoundland Power says mobility is a
big issue crews can't repair what they
can't get to the federal cabinet is
meeting in Winnipeg three ministers
addressed the storm Sunday the defense
minister says about 150 to 200 soldiers
should be on the ground ready to help by
the end of the day this could surge up
to anywhere between 250 to 300 by
tomorrow in the coming days
the search continues for 26 year-old man
missing since the storm
Josh wall disappeared Friday in the town
of roaches line meantime roads around
hospitals have been opened people can
access them as long as they can get out
of their homes progress absolutely but
getting back to normal
all right this way it's still a long way
away Mike arms from Global News the last
thing anyone in Atlantic Canada wanted
was more snow but that's what hit the
Maritimes today people in Nova Scotia
New Brunswick and Prince Edward Island
had shovels in hand as the white stuff
fell and accumulated quickly in places
like Halifax in Fredericton the snowfall
warning has now ended there the same
storm system caused chaos in Toronto
conditions were extremely dangerous for
drivers they were being warned to stay
off the slick roads
hundreds of crashes have been reported
heavy blowing snow and fierce winds made
it near impossible to see in some areas
Montreal is woke up to a winter
wonderland today and are also busy
digging out after the city was blanketed
by snow fortunately no more is in the
immediate forecast snow has been falling
across the prairies as well it's still
falling in Regina where an extreme cold
warning is in place temperatures they
are set to plummet and could drop to
minus 40 degrees tonight with the wind
chill
more than a third of Americans aren't in
the clear just yet bitter cold is
gripping parts of the US hammered by
dangerous winter weather a monster storm
triggered another deadly avalanche and
continues to cause treacherous travel
conditions despite the system moving out
to sea Jennifer Johnson reports
officials are blaming heavy snow for
triggering another deadly avalanche this
time at Farmington Canyon north of Salt
Lake City search and rescue crews tried
to find a trapped 18 year old he was
later flown to a hospital but did not
survive his father says the teens blow
up backpack failed to deploy
another tragedy from a massive winter
storm that has swept across the Upper us
blizzard conditions shut down highways
in North Dakota treacherous driving also
in Michigan
just be careful leave a lot of distance
it's hard to stop police in several
other states report staggering
statistics over 800 kilometers of a
major highway shut down in Nebraska in
Minnesota police reported nearly 200
crashes and in Pennsylvania a pileup
involving 15 tractor trailers closed
busy interstate 90 in both directions at
airports across the country delays and
cancellations put a halt on Trump lers
plans we have passengers we're dealing
with and then just trying to keep the
conditions good even in winter ready New
England crews worked all night to keep
the roads passable it's a quick head
we've got to get out there and spread
salt and traffic will grind the salt in
and keep the road safe until we do that
till it's time to go plow a bizarre
weather change of events for people in
the Northeast
after temperatures hit 21 degrees
Celsius last week as this monster storm
starts to wind down some decided to make
the best of it it's so exciting and
there's so much energy and enthusiasm
down here we're really excited to be
here and spend the day here and this
advice for those who don't like winters
messy weather great I love the weather
you don't like the weather as people dig
out from this massive storm and wind
chills in the Dakotas expected to
plummet to 40 degrees below zero Florida
may look like a tempting option Jennifer
Johnson global news there is sadness and
grief in Ukraine tonight as the bodies
of the victims of downed Ukrainian Air
Lines flight 752 are returned to their
native country the world is still
waiting to find out exactly what
happened in the moments before the plane
was shot down by Iran and his Abigail
Beaman explains there's concern the
Iranian government may be backtracking
on its promise to turn over the black
boxes
at Kiev's Airport a chance to remember
11 victims killed on flight PS 752 as
their bodies return home in Montreal
shared grief at this memorial 57
Canadian citizens were on the plane 29
permanent residents we know 30 have now
been buried in Iran and the prime
minister said this week families want
about 20 victims to come home to Canada
Armen more a table lost his twin brother
and sister-in-law please go investigate
and find what has happened that night it
was a necessary steps to stand up for
their families
Canada's Foreign Affairs Minister flew
to the cabinet retreat in Winnipeg
straight from his rare face-to-face
meeting with his Iranian counterpart I
stress that then I said you know Iran as
a as a pact to choose either they go to
the pad of transparency accountability
and are taking full responsibility when
you say to the world you take full
responsibility that comes with
consequences but since he left new
reports emerged that Iran may not turn
over the black boxes for a third-party
investigation when Francois Philippe
champagne heard that he reached out
again in writing to push for it perhaps
the delay in handing over the black
boxes related to something on that black
box that may implicate Iran furthers the
two Canadian Transportation Safety Board
investigators who were on the ground in
Iran left for Ukraine Sunday after six
days examining the wreckage more are on
standby for when a decision is made
about the black boxes I mean I'm sure
there'll be a more of an update of what
type of work that needs to be done but
one thing I can assure you is we're
working very hard to making sure that
that the investigation that is going to
be conducted is going to be credible and
independent not a lot of answers as the
world waits for Iran's next move and
Canada doesn't have a lot of options
after years of economic sanctions and no
diplomatic relations with Iran abigail
Beeman Global News Winnipeg
a new development on Harry and Megan's
departure from rural service the Duke of
Sussex spoke at an event in London
tonight he says he and his wife had
hoped to continue the Royal duties
without public funding while living an
independent life but Prince Harry says
they couldn't reach an agreement to do
that I've accepted this knowing that it
doesn't change who I am or how committed
I am but I hope that helps you
understand what did it come to that I
would step my family back from all I
have ever known just take us to take a
step forward into what I hope can be a
more peaceful life buckingham palace
confirmed the couple will stop using
their royal highness titles harry megan
and their eight month old son Archie
will divide their time between Canada
and the UK now the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex are classified as internationally
protected persons so technically the
Canadian government must provide them
with security when they visit but their
new deal with the Queen is raising
questions about how much time they will
be spending in Canada and just how much
their security will cost Canadian
taxpayers Canada's public safety
minister says the federal government is
still assessing Canada's role as we do
in every case if individuals require
security that's all determined by a very
thorough assessment assessment by our
officials to determine what's necessary
and and what the costs might might
therefore be but again that
determination has not yet been made
meanwhile Megan's estranged father is
offering some blunt scrutiny of the
situation in a recent interview Thomas
Markel accuses his daughter of
cheapening the royal family and says
he's embarrassed that she and Harry made
this decision she actually got every
girl's dream every young girl wanted to
become a princess and she got that and
now she's tossing that away for it looks
like she's tossing away for money
developing news out of Hawaii tonight
Hawaii's governor confirms two police
officers have been shot and killed in an
area of Honolulu that is popular with
tourists
the officers were responding to an
assault near Diamond Head a popular
monument near
Waikiki Beach that's when a gunman
opened fire on the officers the suspect
was inside a home which caught fire
local media are reporting the suspect
started the fire and he's now dead
thousands of Syrian civilians are on the
move fleeing the fighting between
Russian backed government forces and
armed opposition groups this convoy of
displaced people is heading toward safe
zones near the Turkish border most are
from adlib province it's the last major
rebel controlled area in the country and
Syrian forces are battling to take
control of it the United Nations says at
least 300,000 civilians fled the
violence last month alone a violent turn
to the anti-government protests in
Lebanon security forces in Beirut fired
water cannons tear gas and rubber
bullets on demonstrators who were
throwing stones and lighting aerosol
cans near the Parliament building at
least 370 people were injured over the
weekend including one person who lost an
eye after being hit by a rubber bullet
to Australia now were scientists fear
the scale and severity of the wildfires
will permanently alter the country's
landscape heat waves and a long-running
drought field the biggest wildfire
crisis ever recorded down under a
hundred and four thousand square
kilometres of land were destroyed that's
an area the size of the Maritimes the
government is planning to receive for is
destroyed by fire but experts doubt that
will match the scope of the destruction
coming up the federal plan to rewrite
the rules around medically assisted
dying
one Leto on the go reliable accurate and
easy to use the global news sky tracker
weather app
one of Canada's beloved an influential
artists Gordon Smith has died at the age
of a hundred Smith was born in England
and moved to Canada in the 1930s where
he studied art during the Second World
War he served as an intelligence officer
for the Canadian military Smith was
guided as a painter under the mentorship
of the group of seven artists Lauren
Harris his work can be found in major
art galleries including the one bearing
his own name Smith died at his home in
West Vancouver last night the federal
government is running out of time to put
new medically assisted dying rules in
place last year a Quebec judge deemed
the current law too restrictive and
unconstitutional Ottawa now has less
than two months to rewrite it and as
Linda Ellsworth explains they want your
input on the new legislation which is
expected to be tabled next month when
medical assistants in dying or made
became law in Canada and 2016 many
aspects of the complicated topic were
covered by the bill in particular a
fundamental aspect of that law was the
end-of-life criterion which basically
meant that it was restricted to people
who were at the end of their life and
we're going to pass away anyway the
trouble is with the law by providing a
right to one person you may create
vulnerabilities of others but a few
months ago the Superior Court of Quebec
heard the cases of Nicole gladden and
Jean - Sean who wanted the right to
doctor-assisted deaths even though they
weren't dying I don't want to die I want
to stop the deal I want to stop the
sufferings the ruling the Quebec
Superior Court has said that that part
of the law is unconstitutional and so
the federal ministers of justice and
disability inclusion we're in Vancouver
as part of an eight City cross-canada
tour asking experts on the subject for
input we've had a number of
very interesting roundtables across
Canada from Halifax to Vancouver and
there's a diversity of opinion but but a
lot of interesting and and specific
concrete suggestions in terms of meeting
the the criterion to the Quebec is very
quickly because the court-ordered
deadline is March 11th not much time to
rewrite such a complex law my goal is to
get a draft bill in front of the House
of Commons during the month of February
we haven't ruled out the possibility of
asking for an extension but for the time
being my priority is getting that bill
in front of the house they're also
asking the public to participate in an
online questionnaire as of yesterday
over a hundred and 150 thousand people
had participated in the online survey in
you know in only a short period of time
you'll find it on the Department of
Justice Canada homepage is the
Aylesworth global news still ahead the
bold pleads targeting cargo trucks in
the Greater Toronto Area
staggering new data shows the number of
tractor-trailer thefts and cargo crime
is on the rise in the Greater Toronto
Area thieves are stealing anything from
meat to liquor the Ontario trucking
association says more needs to be done
to combat these crimes including
changing the laws to include stiffer
penalties for those convicted global
Toronto's Camille Cara Malley reports
this video uploaded to YouTube this
drunken stolen appears to show a
Brampton man going head-to-head with a
tractor trailer thief before the alleged
cargo criminal drives off something
trucking company manager harm Ajith Jan
has seen firsthand it is definitely a
concern cargo theft has been a concern
for the last five years around the
Greater Toronto Area only peel and York
Regional Police have units dedicated to
tackling cargo and tractor-trailer
thefts the number of robberies in the
past five years in Peel has soared in
2015
ninety eight cases of cargo theft in
2018 that jumped to a whopping 341 cases
reported the GTA is the hotbed of cargo
crime in Canada there are more goods
stolen in Canada than all of the US and
2018 peel region comes only behind
California as the highest jurisdiction
for cargo crime police say the criminals
will steal anything including meat
that's what was in the stolen tractor
trailer that rammed into a gas station
just outside Toronto killing the driver
a rare fatality in what police call a
low-risk high-reward crime with the bad
guys netting roughly 30% of the stolen
goods value after reselling we've had
loads million dollars worth so you do
the math they're making pretty good
money for One Nights work
the Ontario trucking association says
that money is used to fund more
nefarious criminal activity it's easy
because police are struggling to keep up
and a justice system that allows the
cargo thieves to walk right back out
onto the streets they're usually
released within
24 hours and there unfortunately back
out doing exactly what they were doing
before
truckers are calling for change I think
the laws need teeth the laws as are
currently written do not differentiate
between simple crime and cargo crime
police say part of the responsibility is
also on the trucking companies to beef
up security
Camila Kamali Global News Toronto up
next we check in on st. John's
Newfoundland in the aftermath of the
storm
most people in st. John's are still
digging themselves out of the
record-breaking levels of snowfall that
buried them this weekend as we reported
earlier the military is mobilizing to
assist but for now it's neighbor helping
neighbor the weather networks Chris
Murphy is there to give us a little
perspective on the snowy situation all
right well you clearly see today it's
all about the big dig digging out look
at the size of these snow banks it's
unreal I have never seen this as a
result of one storm maybe back to back
to back
we call this that's the cavalry right
there hooking up the power now they've
done most of the larger grids now
they're just working their way down the
line and trying to get everybody there
but as we just take a little walk here I
mean for all we know there could be
stars under these snow banks but those
have been digging out I've also been
noticing a lot of people helping each
other out so people have been asking me
yes its record-breaking is this an
unprecedented storm
well we actually get storms like this
our storms similar size almost every
year it's just this year it was st.
John's turn to get hit it just hit the
sweet spot and call this a weather bomb
and that what happens is that the
barometric pressure plummets at least 24
millibars in 24 hours or less
essentially it means that it's like a
storm and then it gets injected by
steroids and that's how we happened we
had the cold air from the continent
colliding with that warm air coming up
from the Gulf Stream the last time I
could ever remember storm anything
comparable to this would have been the
one known as white one back in February
2004 Maritimers remember they're still
talking about that storm in Halifax and
this one here well this one's for the
books no doubt about it talking with
power this rivals you know some of the
bad ice storms we've had if you look
back at our rich history of Canadian
winter storms we'll have to add one more
I guess we should come up with a name
for it I'll let other people decide that
so going forward well we got to take
advantage of the calm conditions and
clear skies because there's more snow
coming in tonight another 10 15 plus
centimeters of snow and that means that
people will be digging out again
tomorrow so it won't compare to this but
it will be adding a little bit of insult
to injury
as it were but just one more look
everybody doing their job to the city
crews they've been really big thumbs up
thanks Chris and that is global national
for this Sunday I'm Robin Gill tonight
your Canada is a resilient Robin in a
snowstorm in Oshawa Ontario thank you
for watching
Donna freeze and we'll be back here
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]